Thanks, Michael. Now, let's move on to our final sleep disorder that we're
going to cover, insomnia. This is probably the most commonly known sleep
disorder. This can result in people having difficulty falling asleep, staying
asleep, or both. Either one of these or both of them results in a poor quality
of sleep. And the individual will wake up tired and not well rested. We've
already learned about the physical and mental effects of sleep deprivation, so
chronic insomnia may result in detrimental healthy consequences. Acute insomnia
can result from stressful events we experience, traumas or work and family
pressures. It can last from days to weeks. In addition to feeling less
energetic, insomnia may cause one to feel irritable, anxious, even depressed.
This again makes a clear point that adequate sleep and quality of sleep is
essential for our physical and mental health.